sup guys we are about to go through
doing the zelda breath of the wild booth
tour at Nintendo know the theme park
holy crap I just got like teary eyes
so when you step on this little dirt
patch it makes the food move ready
this is Sony it's like
forest video games
this is so awesome Reggie thanks so much
for hanging out with us in me today
absolutely happy to have you here so
we're talking about e3 we're here at e3
now what is different about this game
three for you guys than previous years
you know for us every III is different
we approach it as a unique opportunity
to show our best content to the world
and so some years we do is big pressure
some years we do a Nintendo Direct this
year it was all about Zelda breath of
the wild and it was all about getting
people to have a hands-on experience
because this is a game that a
three-minute trailer and a five minute
demo is just not enough and so in order
to get as many people as possible to get
their hands on the game we dedicated the
whole booth to the game and the booth is
so incredible because like the madness
that surrounds e3 there's people
everywhere but when you walk in it's
like this serene experience and it was
that summit you guys of attention it
really is and the the whole experience
of getting a bit of a tutorial as you're
coming into the booth you know it
unveils and and you have you know all of
these these models of the the different
elements from the Zelda game itself and
then all of these Interactive's and then
going through two different experiences
because we wanted people to get
comfortable with the controls and then
we wanted to then see the game from the
start and it's it's wide open the way
you play it
could be very different will be very
different than the way I play it and in
order to make all of that happen we have
to dedicate the entire space so diving
into the game and what do you think
people can expect you haven't got a
chance
well I I think what you could expect is
that the zelda convention has been
turned upside down meaning it is no
longer progression from one dungeon to
the next it is a progression where you
as the player can do whatever you want
we saw bill Trenton yesterday from our
treehouse team play in the shorts that
link has when he wakes up after a
hundred years slumber you could do that
you could progress up the entire game as
a vegetarian oh right just just taking
the nuts and the mushrooms and cooking
those up for your health parts of a meal
I'm making a meal throw those in there
to cook it looks up he's singing
and he gets excited and obviously
there's so much talk of nxn you guys
aren't talking about any of that but
they're going to be huge difference
between games or is it going to be
pretty similar for both so what we've
said is absolutely it's going to be
available simultaneously for the two
different platforms the differences will
show those off in the future as we get
more in depth into what MX is and what
is the real name of NX and what does it
do and all those things that's all
coming and during that experience will
help people understand what are the
differences between these two yeah I
mean we ours is so huge and like even
playing this game like I could see
what that would be like like living in
that world and feeling that is that
something that you guys think could be a
possibility or you know so let me let me
break the question down so like I said
exactly so you know we constantly think
about what could be the the next great
adventure for the Zelda plan were right
and Zelda as a franchise 75 million
units sold 30 years old it's big but
what we want to do is continue to find
new ways for people to come into the
franchise hopefully breath of the wild
will be a step in doing that VR I've
tried every VR experience including
stuff that isn't here and is being shown
only by the particular manufacturers
only in closed doors and I still feel
that it is an interesting technology and
it's progressing technology but it's not
ready for primetime yet
I had an experience today where I still
felt a little queasy
I had a similar experience as well so I
think whenever Nintendo figures that out
then it's gonna be ready to hit
mainstream on and that's what we do we
create mainstream content and so we look
at all technologies we constantly
evaluate them and what we say is when
any technology is going to be ready for
mainstream
that's when we'll be there that's
awesome now
huge amiibo fan like I actually have a
problem I'm obsessed so how do you see
an evokes are playing instances over
well so we're showing three
fantastically designed amiibo resultant
we haven't said exactly what the
functionality is and exactly what it
does but you can get a taste of that
from the wolf link amiibo which is
available with twelve Twilight Princess
what that gives you is the wolf in the
game that acts as attacker as you're
going after the various enemies which is
way cool starts with three hearts but if
you build it up to 10 hearts 13 hearts
it has that as you scan it into the game
so that's really cool that's just a
small taste of what we're looking to do
but you can expect the types of
functionality that we'll add in the
middle so typical sort of Zelda games
there's like concurrency as far as route
pieces insert and that's a little bit
different in this game so can you talk a
little bit about that yeah I mean again
the the typical conventions are
different so when you cut down the grass
you won't find any rupees and you won't
find any hearts what you have to do is
you have to find the various elements
out in the wild and then you craft so
you can craft an elixir you can craft a
skewer of meat and mushrooms and what
that does is extend your your hearts for
a temporary time period there anything
else that you want to let people know
what to look forward to you know again
what I would say is this game has been a
labor of love by our developers for
so I one hand we apologize for the
length of development but on the other
hand this is a fantastic game if you
keep zooming out you'll get a sense for
just how huge this space and you're
gonna you're going to go explore all of
this as I said yeah that's that's about
1% of the entire what that's that's 1%
that's 1% because I could keep going
back all of this you know still hasn't
been hasn't been unlocked at this point
it boggles the mind the amount of
content that we're making available just
during these demos and and the fact that
each of us will play differently I mean
this is this is a place this is a game
you'll get lost
thank you did you throw up your sword
and your sword Oh run away run away
first I'm gonna pick these up this is
some Rick suburb also some peas
interesting because this you know the
maps are so cute I mean you can fly
exactly you can climb up and anything
you see you can interact with so as you
climb you've got your health meter here
so one of the things you want to be
careful about is you want to traverse by
a ledge or somewhere where you can kind
of recapture your stamina
I stand that no no if you go down a
little bit more I'm just gonna jump down
there you go great so what else can we
expect like anything else that we don't
like surprised to find in this game I
mean there's so many different things
that that are again unique and different
within the zelda convention there's mom
I'm super into this the moms are great
there's two different types of bombs
there's the round bombs that you throw a
roll there's another one with a flat
bottom those are ones use a place in a
particular area and then step back away
and
thank you so much for chatting with us
great thank you Oh Steve I got Reggie on
my straight path Reggie what did you do
to her here there is
all right here we go yes yes - get up we
hope so exciting